this is super funny i told you guys on
yesterday's show that donald trump's
impeachment lawyers just quit on him
and donald trump yesterday was able to
get new
impeachment lawyers at least one a guy
named david shone
and he went on fox news last night with
sean hannity and
he just imploded showing us instantly
what this impeachment trial is going to
be like
here is donald trump's new impeachment
lawyer again a bunch of his lawyers quit
he got a new guy
telling sean hannity that he might call
democratic senators or as he calls them
democrat senators as witnesses
over what he calls bias what
yeah i don't know either let's take a
look march to the capitol so your voices
can get heard
and they take you right yeah yeah there
are two points about this
i would say you also should be able to
call then uh many of the senators as
witnesses
because of the awful bias and
prejudgment they've shown
can you imagine any american citizen
considering it to be a
trial in which the judge and jury
has already announced publicly that the
defendant must be convicted
in this case and in fact um senator
leahy called
demanded that senator mcconnell vote for
conviction also um
you know both sides everyone it's clear
to them donald trump undercut
undercut democracy how can we possibly
have a fair trial
chuck schumer senator schumer promised a
fair and full trial
you can't when you know that the juror
and the judge are biased going in
notice at the start that sean hannity is
actually defending trump's role in
inciting the insurrection
saying listen he was telling people to
go to the capitol to have their voices
heard
and it's funny to say democratic
senators are doing
something wrong by calling for
conviction
before the trial remember trump's first
impeachment
when republican senators prejudged an
acquittal of donald trump
where was this guy then where was sean
hannity then saying you know
the trial hasn't happened yet so they
really shouldn't be prejudging it
they're not going to be calling any
democratic senators as witnesses anyway
by the way then trump's impeachment
lawyer says
he doesn't want any videos of the
insurrection shown at the trial
he says this has nothing to do with
donald trump in
the second thing is does this country
really need to see videotapes we know
now apparently
that mr swalwell and the other managers
tend to show videotapes of the riots and
people calling in
people being hurt police officers
talking why does the country need that
now we would stipulate that there was a
riot
that went on that day it was a tragedy
president trump has condemned violence
at all times read the words of his
speech calls for peacefulness
this has nothing to do with president
trump and the country doesn't need to
just watch
videos of riots and unrest we need to
heal now
we need to move forward is that the
speech trump
gave when the riot was already over that
david shone is referring to
or then the one that he gave days later
where he retroactively condemned the
violence that he was
gleefully loving based on reports from
the actual day of january 6th
it's funny how david shone keeps saying
the country doesn't need to see videos
of the trump riot
the trial is for senators now i
understand
it's nationally televised i know the
country will see
whatever evidence is put forward but the
trial
is for the senators to adjudicate what
justification is there
for not including relevant video
evidence
during the trial for the people who are
going to be adjudicating
guilt or innocence or guilt or lack of
guilt to make it easier for them to
acquit
maybe he doesn't want the videos put up
there
oh i don't know that that footage was
never presented and you'll remember that
kelly lefler
hilariously said at one point during her
senatorial campaign
when asked about the trump uh grab him
by the you know what tape oh i don't
what what tape is that i don't know
the reason you put the footage in front
of in front of the senators during the
trial is so nobody can say
listen i don't know based on what i saw
during the trial which is all we're
supposed to consider
i didn't see any reason to convict
donald trump now the republicans aren't
going to convict them anyway
but at least expose them for the shills
that they are by putting all of the
evidence in front of them including
video of the riot
now one last clip here's a possible
preview of the defense strategy
which is to call the entire thing
unconstitutional and you've hit
many of the main arguments that i think
are attractive the american people
they're all right on but i'm going to
say to you that besides the fact that
this process is completely
unconstitutional
and that this is a very very dangerous
road to take with respect to the first
amendment putting it
risk any uh passionate political speaker
uh which is um really an and against
everything we believe in in this country
foundation of the first amendment but
i'm going to tell you i think it's also
the most ill-advised
legislative action that i've seen in my
lifetime it is
tearing the country apart at a time when
we don't need anything like that
i think president biden missed a great
opportunity to be a statesman
and demanded that this thing be called
off frankly
this is the political weaponization of
the impeachment process
there was a rush to judgment listen when
president trump
became president the day he was elected
there were calls for his impeachment
ready this is the weapon they've tried
to use against him
um but now we know also that the agenda
um mrs pelosi and others is simply to
bar president
trump from ever running for president
again and that's about as undemocratic
as you can get
can you imagine the slap in the face
that is to the 75 million
or more voters who voted for donald
trump
so this is not a first amendment issue
donald trump as president had the
biggest bully pulpit
in the world he used it and that bully
pulpit
caused a riot now there are possible
consequences for that speech there
won't be because trump will be acquitted
but these are the possible consequences
to your speech david shone calling for
joe biden to demand the trial be called
off by the way is ridiculous as i've
said
for weeks and months now joe biden
should have no involvement
whatsoever in the impeachment trial
trump was impeached by the house before
joe biden was even president
biden should do nothing one way or the
other period
and then david shone even sort of
placates i don't know if you noticed
this
he placates the stop the steel
conspiracists he says
the 75 million or more voters who voted
for trump
that's a dog whistle that's the
suggestion that
okay 75 million people officially voted
for trump
but there may even be more uncounted
votes out there
that we still need to respect as well
this guy is absolutely
pathetic here's he's merely a political
hatchet man
a political tool he should be ashamed of
of himself and the trial starts one week
from today
and we will be covering much of it one
of our sponsors today is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads the water sprays with a ton of
pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up really easy and it's been a
totally different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
but the first hundred people who go to
nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get
15 percent off all nebia products the
link is underneath this video